is property investing dead it's
september
2021 and property prices have absolutely
rocketed all across the country and in
many parts of the world now as property
prices go up that actually means that
it's harder for investors and first-time
buyers to get the deposit together to
buy a property
as a buy to let investor the higher
prices are then that means that your
deposit is higher also stamp duty
holiday has now ended so the amount of
money that you have to put down to buy
an average house is significantly higher
than it was a few years ago
that being said it's much harder to get
the returns that you could get back in
the day especially with things like the
tenants rights tenants now if there's a
bad tenant to get rid of them is a
process it's expensive and then you've
also got problems like the tax changes
section 24 that have meant that you
can't claim your mortgage expense back
as tax deductible unless you buy through
a company which of course means that you
have to pay an accountant to do your
accounts so is the profit being squeezed
out of buy to let property so much so
that it doesn't make sense anymore to
save deposits and buy a property and
build a portfolio well my thinking is
whenever the market changes you need to
be creative and you need to find new
ways to win in property buy to let
vanilla straight forward buy to let is
less attractive than it was
five ten fifteen years ago i first
bought my first bite property in 2009
it's now 2021. there's a lot of changes
house prices have doubled in value in
most parts of the country so what is the
solution how can property as a vehicle
continue to be
productive
profitable and how can you recycle your
deposits and get more for your money
wow
what i think property investors should
start looking at now instead of buying a
property with the view to rent the
property out and get a high return or a
high yield i think it's much more
lucrative if you can find properties
instead of finding properties that would
make good rentals
is to find properties that have got
something wrong with them
find a rundown property that's
unmortgageable or maybe there's no
kitchen there's no bathroom if there's
no kitchen or bathroom in a property you
cannot get a mortgage on that property
so all the buy to let investors all the
first-time buyers
cannot compete with these rundown
problem properties
how are you going to compete then how
are you going to buy these properties
well what you're going to do is you're
going to instead of getting a mortgage
you're gonna buy them with a bridging
loan
now some people are scared about
bridging loans because they're expensive
they've not done them before they're
afraid of the unknown however when you
know what you're doing bridging loans
can be a very good tool
so
let's say you find a rundown property
let's say you agree to buy it nice and
cheap and you buy it with a bridging
loan instead of a mortgage you're still
going to need a deposit you're going to
use a bridging loan this property is now
effectively as far as the seller is
concerned it's a cash purchase there's
no mortgage bridging is expensive but
it's also very very quick this also
opens you up to auction properties and
all of the rundown nasty properties that
nobody's interested in and nobody can
compete with because they need a
mortgage to buy their properties
once you've bought these rundown problem
properties what are you going to do are
you going to rent them out well you
can't because they're in such bad
condition
so what you're going to do is you're
going to fix these properties up you're
going to get a new kitchen a new
bathroom you're gonna if there's a
structural problem you're gonna fix it
once you've done this you've pushed the
value of the property up
now you'll find that the property is
mortgageable which means that it's
suddenly going to be achievable a much
higher price for that property
you're going to then take out a mortgage
and the mortgage is going to pay back
the bridging company and in some cases
it's going to pay you back more than the
bridging loan and you will get your
deposit back in full
then you can rent the property out
you've got your deposit back to go again
and again and again this strategy you've
probably heard of as the buy refurbish
refinance rent it means you can recycle
the small money you have instead of
leaving it down as a deposit on a buy to
let property mean you can recycle your
money and build a larger portfolio
making more profit and this is the new
way of investing in 2021.
if you'd like to see an example of this
done i'd highly recommend that you watch
a documentary that i made where i showed
you the a to z
of finding buying refurbing refinancing
a property i show you me doing this with
one of my properties up north in
darlington and if you'd like to watch
that video i'm going to leave it right
up here for you to watch please also do
like the video if you enjoyed this and
don't forget to subscribe and i'll see
you on the next video